what's going on guys this is rob and uh
mutants have existed this entire time in
the marvel cinematic universe
and marvel basically told us they did
now part of this theory is not new and
has actually really been circulating
around for a long long time but
part of it is and i want to know your
thoughts on this okay so let's start off
with the part that you guys do know and
have a little bit of a refresher course
when it comes to wanda this scholar
which so a popular theory out there
right now is that wanda is gonna do like
a reverse house of m that wanda is
basically instead of taking away 98 of
the mutant population's powers she's
actually going to give powers to people
and then basically create mutants that
way which i'm not entirely sure i agree
with but focusing on this sort of quick
little origin here the first question
you really gotta ask is like how did
wanna get her powers and the answer is
we're never given an answer all we're
really told here is that when wanda was
really really young that a stark bomb
fell through her house killed her
parents and that her powers essentially
kept the bomb from going off right they
manifested when she was a little kid now
fast forward to the events of her being
in sokovia and effectively being like a
freedom fighter protester now as we know
from the post-credits scene with captain
america the winter soldier i don't know
which one it was but basically like
baron von strucker was like isn't it age
of miracles you know it's an age of
mutants we all kind of knew what he was
saying even though marvel couldn't
officially say it uh we basically saw
that wanda's powers were essentially
activated alongside pietro's powers by
way of the mind stone following that of
course juana goes on to basically become
a ally of ultron and then basically turn
code and then like the rest is history
and the marvel cinematic universe right
you guys know all that kind of stuff now
here's the kicker and the caveat to this
wanda's been a mutant this whole time
i think that's going to be the big thing
so when it comes to doctor strange 2
right and this is something that we we
keep on talking about right when it
comes to doctor strange too the big
thing is xavier is like let's tell him
the truth i think the truth of what
xavier is going to tell dr strange is
wanda is not just some arbitrary person
who can manipulate magic one is a mutant
she's a mutant and there's a lot more of
her like there's a lot more people like
her than simply just her and your
universe you just don't know about them
we'll talk about that a little bit here
in a second because
post-credits scene
i have a really good idea for a post
credit scene so here's here's a question
i would ask you what's the big
difference between someone like agatha
harkness or someone like doctor strange
and wanda right what sets her apart from
them the big difference here is they had
to learn how to use magic that the
origin of agatha harkness at least as it
was given to us in juan division is she
was part of a witch's coven and then she
basically started delving into what was
essentially black magic and then of
course was gonna be killed by her coven
and then she basically reversed the
spell and then killed her covenant
instead including her mom and then just
went forward from there but she had to
learn how to use her powers she wasn't
born with the ability to use magic
doctor strange was the exact same way i
mean we all literally watched that movie
the guy was a surgeon who didn't even
believe that magic existed and then
ultimately became the sorcerer supreme
wanda was not that way there's nothing
to indicate that wanda was part of like
a witch's coven and was whisked away to
safety to the land of sokovia war-torn
and everything where she was raised
alongside her brother and then her
parents died in a bombing right there's
nothing to indicate that that's the case
more so than that if we tie in this idea
that what wanda has here is an x gene it
explains a lot it explains one where her
powers came from in the first place two
how she's so adept at using them despite
having no formal training because that's
one thing to remember wanda has no
formal training in magic there's never
been any reference in the marvel
cinematic universe where doctor strange
has taken wanda under his wing and
taught her how to use her powers that's
never been the case but she is
prodigious at being able to use those
abilities even when she was using them
in somewhat of a minor level by the time
she showed up in age of ultron and was
like using her powers against the
avengers she knew what she was doing
right so seemingly she'd been doing it
for a little while she basically seemed
to be self-taught this also explains why
wanda is so incredibly powerful so
here's the thing when it comes to magic
and marvel comics i know the marvel
cinematic universe plays by its own
rules and wanda uses chaos magic but
that's a similarity with the comics so
there's all kinds of magical energy that
exists out there in in mobile comics say
for example somebody like doctor strange
doctor strange of course as you guys
know does not have any powers in and of
himself he borrows powers from other
magical beings like 80 of his magical
power comes from a group called the
vashanti a trinity of just super
powerful magical beings but the the
things that doctor strange can do are
limited to the abilities of the people
he borrows magic from so let's say for
example that the vashanti did not have
the ability to teleport right that's
something they just simply couldn't do i
mean they can but like let's say they
weren't able to do that doctor strange
can draw on the power of the vishanti
but he can't teleport he can only really
do what they can do now because that's
not an ability of ashanti have doctor
strange can like borrow that ability
from other people and so that's why you
see at least in the comics in the the
marvel cinematic universe doctor strange
invoking the spells of different people
because different magical beings can do
stuff that other magical beings simply
just can't do a lot of them are very
unique so like the crimson bands of
sidorak sidorak is the only one who can
do that right it's not the crimson bands
of dormammu right the crimson bands of
zom which by the way man
i really hope they introduce zom in the
marvel cinematic universe let me tell
you something in the hierarchy of like
evil magical beings or just magical
beings in general there's zom
then there's everybody else this guy is
just on a whole different level right
like the guy was so powerful the living
tribunal the living embodiment of the
multiverse had to step in to stop this
guy the like eternity the living
embodiment of the universe could not
defeat him he's just that powerful it's
ridiculous how opi's audience but
nonetheless back on track
you know wanda having an x gene that
allows her to manipulate magic would
explain all this and the reason for that
is because if it is an inherent ability
of hers by virtue of her mutant power to
manipulate magical energy then unlike dr
strange where the doors of chaos magic
are essentially close to him they're not
close to wanda no doors are closed to
her right there is no source of ambient
magical energy that she cannot
manipulate chaos energy is the most
powerful form of magical energy you can
do anything with chaos energy right you
can alter reality you can you can turn a
coffee cup into a pencil you can read
people's minds control people's minds if
you can imagine it it could be done the
price you pay for using chaos magic is
you basically begin to bind yourself to
cathone and then ultimately you will be
irrevocably stuck to him right so
essentially you can make yourself into a
vector right now with juan it's a little
bit different she's kind of forced down
that road because the the nature of her
being able to manipulate chaos magic in
the comics is tied directly to the fact
that her powers are actually from
catholic himself in the marvel cinematic
universe that doesn't seem to be the
case now here's the reason why i say
there's so much credence to this idea so
one of the best kept secrets of the
marvel cinematic universe that almost
nobody knows about is they release
comics people don't really know that
right people aren't aware of the fact
that like the marvel cinematic universe
releases what are called infinity comics
basically they're digital only comics uh
but these are basically kind of tie-ins
or things that happen in between
different events so like the infinity
comic for the prelude to age of ultron
sixty percent of that's basically the
post-credits scene where baron von
strucker is like this isn't major
miracles and all that kind of crap but
there is a point in that story as well
as in the books of wakanda that was
released to tie into the marvel
cinematic universe where you learn the
reason why hydra had set up shop in
sokovia by grabbing people and bringing
them in and using the mind stone on them
is because they had detected genetic
abnormalities among some of the citizens
in sokovia they didn't know what those
abnormalities were they didn't know what
those abnormalities meant all they knew
is that they were simply just there and
so using the mind stone on the
volunteers basically those individuals
that they had spoken to who had genetic
abnormalities who in turn agreed to
partake in those experiments in an
effort to gain enough power to basically
free their country that seemingly
everybody except for wanda and pietro
died now that's an important distinction
there because not everybody who had some
kind of genetic abnormality sided with
hydra and actually went in and performed
or was inducted in those experiments not
all those people did so what that means
is that if those genetic abnormalities
are basically people with mutant genes
they're out there right there are some
who are just enzokovia right or maybe
left sokovia and are now traveling
throughout the rest of the world but
basically the marvel cinematic universe
told us that this is doubly important
when you look at wanda because one thing
to understand is that mutant genes only
activate under one of three
circumstances like 90 to 95 is just
puberty right so you're some 13 year old
boy and you start getting hair in funny
places start thinking about girls and
then you learn you can teleport right so
like something along those lines
the remaining five to ten percent only
happened under one of two circumstances
the first is that those powers are
artificially activated and that's what
happened to wolverine in the ultimate
universe when canada was trying to
create super soldiers they discovered
wolverine had some kind of a gene they
didn't recognize when they activated it
he developed a healing factor the other
scenario is moments of high duress now
marvel never really explains or
reconciles that right there have been
instances where mutants like like kids
have been confronted with just like
overwhelmingly stressful situations and
their powers never manifest other times
it does right there have been times when
like two mutants will be facing some
overwhelming situation and only one of
their powers will manifest so it's not
an absolute thing but moments of high
duress is when mutant powers can also
activate
what is a greater moment of high duress
than a bomb falling in your house
killing your parents and you being too
young to genuinely understand what's
going on right running purely on your
subconscious and your instincts right
like that's a recipe for a mutant power
to activate so that's what i think is
going to happen like the the scene when
literally xavier is talking to dr
strange when he says like let's tell him
the truth i think that's going to be the
first time that's going to be the bomb
that's going to be like the just a
hammer hitting where xavier is just like
wanda's a mutant she's not some random
person who's a witch that can manipulate
magical energy she is a mutant
m-u-t-a-n-t
steven strange i think that's basically
what's gonna happen and that's gonna be
huge now i'm gonna blow your minds for a
second right post credit scene time so
imagine over the course of this movie at
some point after doctor strange meets
with the illuminati probably talking to
baron mordo when he's like so is there
like a variant of everybody across the
multiverse and bear motors like yeah man
there's an alternate reality where you
basically had kids with christine palmer
and he lived happily ever after and
there was an alternate reality where you
basically killed the ancient one and
then became sorcerer supreme killed
everybody else around the world who
could challenge you and then subjugated
earth which is kind of a story that i
want to see if i'm being honest with you
guys but he's like yeah i mean there are
variants of us right the illuminati all
across the multiverse right we exist
everywhere and so based on that right
that's when your mind starts going and
it's like did they just tell us there's
a variant of charles xavier in the
marvel cinematic universe cut to the
post-credits scene right so like you get
the you get the sound like you know the
sound you hear when like dr strange is
landing like the rippling cloak sound
you get that sound and like literally he
just lands and he just starts walking
forward he goes through these gates and
as he's walking the camera pans away
from him and to the right and there's a
sign that says xavier's school for
gifted youngsters if i want to blow your
minds even more
[Laughter]
remember that theory we had about vision
knowing about mutants i think that'd be
a great way to segue those guys who
aren't really familiar with that there
was this theory that we had something
like six months ago where basically when
vision got the mind stone he learned
that mutants were real he learned that
xavier had actually been hiding the
existence of mutants from everybody
across the world and vision went to
xavier and was like okay so like talk
because there's literally
millions of people walking around who
all have powers and can do extraordinary
things and no one seems to know and it's
all because of you so like what's going
on here pops and xavier is just like if
the world learned we existed they would
kill us like they would they would hunt
us down they would hate us right people
attack what they don't understand just
look at everything vision right like
literally ultron became self-aware
learned about the internet and after
five minutes decided humanity didn't
need to exist you guys have heard you
guys have seen that meme right like like
come on vision you have to understand
and ultimately you know for real over
true being serious here vision actually
understands what xavier is saying and
it's like
i agree with you if the world learned
that you guys existed they would hunt
you down right or they would imprison
you or they would experiment on you or
something along those lines the world
can't know you exist and so ultimately
vision leaves and we never learn about
mutants because what is the marvel
cinematic universe if not us basically
observing the interpersonal
relationships and conflicts between
various characters it's not like we're a
person in that room they're not breaking
the fourth wall and addressing us as the
audience that's what deadpool does
that's his thing so we're just observing
them and if vision made a promise to
xavier that he would never ever tell
anybody about the x-men or mutants
existing in the mcu he would never bring
it up because he told xavier he wouldn't
he wouldn't tell tony stark or bruce
banner or any of those guys no one would
know he'd basically be the one that kept
the secret the funny thing about this
though is that i'm pretty sure
nick fury knows too but having said that
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end let me know what you guys think
about this theory down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace